so good morning NDC and thank you all
for coming to my little talk at 9 00 am
after the party that's that's a big vote
of confidence I thank you
so uh I can see that we are we are ready
to start
so this is a little talk that I've named
how hacking works and this is a web
Edition and I had another one at NDC
security which was a much broader one
when they do more different kinds of
subjects but today we're only going to
focus on the web and web applications
and web vulnerabilities
but before we get started let's do the
obligatory who am I so you get to know
me a little bit so my name is Aspen
sandal arson I worked as a developer for
the better part of 25 years and I've had
several roles over the years I've been
developer a tech lead architect even a
hacker
but uh you may also not know that I am a
musician I release music you can listen
to me on Spotify or not hashtag
Shameless plug
and I'm the father of three and I really
love to do Tech stuff not just for work
for my hobbies as well so my hobbies are
kind of like everything computer related
but also like flying drones and when I'm
not tinkering with hardware and software
and stuff like that I really enjoy
drinking beer and having fun and doing
all sorts of mischievous stuff
and my job is I work at DMB bank it's
this little Bank in the nordics and I
work in a division called the new Tech
Lab and new Tech Lab is this kind of r d
division that gets to play with new
technologies and Cutting Edge stuff
so I get to play with the all the latest
and greatest and used toys and build
like projects and code up experiments
and stuff like that and part of that is
security and doing security research and
currently working on Quantum Computing
and breaking encryption using quantum
computers which is kind of fun
and before we proceed I have to do this
obligatory one as well this is a
disclaimer this is legalese saying that
everything you're about to hear that I'm
saying is me saying and not necessarily
DMB saying so with that said that's out
of the way
I got started out in Computing back in
what I like to refer to as the golden
days I started out with this magical
machine some of you may have seen it
some of you may have played with it some
of you may think what the hell is that
thing it's the Commodore 64 and it was
this amazing machine that my brother
bought bought home he had traded a piece
of illicit substance for this computer
and ever since that day I got hooked on
computers and not drugs
and it was uh it was amazing to try to
get that thing to work
I remember the first time we got it
because we didn't get a manual or
anything or a game so all you had was an
operating system which basically was a
programming language
um in order to get it to do stuff you
had to program it
and we didn't have like JavaScript or
higher level stuff back then you had to
really know that machine and figure out
how it worked you had to figure out the
memory model and the instruction sets of
stuff like that in order to get it to do
stuff
which is why I feel that I may have a
little bit of an advantage when it comes
to the security related stuff because
that taught me to be curious and poke at
things and try to figure out how stuff
really works under the hood
but in order to discuss what hacking is
and how it works we need to didn't know
exactly what is hacking what do we mean
when we talk about hacking and what
better do to do than consult Hollywood
and movies and TV because they clearly
have a good understanding right
so this is from a TV show called NCIS
there's a hack in progress and they have
to defend against it and that's how it
looks like
there's no sound
no no this is Major yeah so you're
getting hacked and the way you know
you're getting hacked is you get a
million pop-ups
and the way you defend against an attack
is you get on a keyboard you just bash
out the keys and what's better than one
Defender with two Defenders on the same
keyboard because that's how keyboards
work
and computers evidently
and of course in order to save the day
it's not the professionals it's the
non-technical person who just strolls
casually into the room oh we're getting
hacked awesome
one with a sandwich
and there's non-technical person solves
the entire
Thing by doing this
no
excited so he just unplugged the
computer because that's how you stop an
attack because in this entire government
organization
all the essential files and documents
and things that attackers want to access
was not one single terminal that's how
it works
uh is it possible to get more sound on
the videos please yeah
because the next one is really important
that you listen well because this is a
TV show about forensic Specialists and
analysts and this is NCSI
and just listen to this gem they've
evidently did the research right
weeks I've been investigating the candy
killer murders with a certain morbid
Fascination this is in real time
I'll create a GUI interface using Visual
Basic see if I can track an IP address
Basic and see if I can find an IP
address
I don't even know how to comment on that
evidently they didn't even bother okay
so yeah what about a movie that's named
hackers they probably get it right right
they have to do research just look at
that keyboard
so there's a virus and the virus eats
memory like Pac-Man
type cookie you idiot and you just cut
cookie to get it away
and of course the defender has to go
into the street environment and shoot
down the attackers using lasers
look at this yeah
that take that you hackers
and of course you have this circular key
keyboard
a rabbit is in the administration system
send a flu shot that sounds bad flu shot
someone talk to me a rabbit uh
replicates till it overloads of files
and it spreads like cancer cancer yeah
now that's not a thing and these
keyboards aren't aren't a thing either
how about a show that's about a hacker
that's the entire plot of the show they
probably did some research right so in
this scene there's malware on a plane
and they have to figure out how to patch
that plane and the only way to do so is
the programmer has to get or the hacker
has to go in his Ferrari catch up to the
plane
in mid-flight over the runway
and therefore the person from The Fly
crew has to climb down on the landing
gear
because it the only way to patch the
plane is to plug in an ethernet cable
into a laptop
so there's yeah
[Music]
three
this is my favorite nonsensical example
of everything so of course they're
running out the runway
so what you do
you have to stretch
so that the player has to gain attitude
because it has to clear the tower
and they're running out of table
[Music]
so yeah yeah that's that's how hacking
works
yeah
so that that's all nonsense of course
but let's define what hacking really is
because it used to mean something
different back in the day it used to
mean people who were tinkering with
software and hardware and they kind of
use components outside the other scope
of what they were intended intended to
do one such example that's one of my
favorites is the woznek who built the
color output for the Apple II and it
designed that by just modifying the
video signal a little bit and that will
cause the ray cannon inside the screen
to misalign and that caused colors to be
able to appear on the screen
so by doing so with the circuitry he was
able to build a computer with a color
interface without having a video chip
which is pretty cool
and that was what they used to refer to
as hackers so they had to like think
outside the box and they had to like
figure out how stuff works
but what we refer to as hacking today
was originally called freaking and
that's because it comes from the word
phone and freak
um because back then in order to
communicate with computers yeah you had
to like call them up on the phone
because we used the phone lines for
communications back then
and if you were good at exploiting
vulnerabilities you were a freak and you
did it on the phone so freaking what's
the thing but now we call that hacking
because we kind of evolved away from
phone lines and phone systems
but essentially what we're talking about
in the scope of this talk and this
session today it's exploiting systems
through their vulnerabilities
and this is where I usually do an
audience poll because this talking take
a couple of different turns depending on
the audience
but I can't see any of you because
there's big lights so I guess instead of
raising hands you make a sound
to just say if you agree with the
statement or something like that
so just how many of you are programmers
coders you write code for a living
awesome
that sounded like like a chant maybe we
could get like a developer chant going
anyways okay any tech leads Architects
uh like you design the systems not
necessarily code the systems
yeah some of those
how about security Engineers pen testers
Chief security officers
hackers
okay
how about something completely different
like scrum Masters or project managers
okay
proudly announcing that awesome cool
well that's good that gives me some
ideas for the demo section that's coming
up in a bit
uh in order to Define hacker we also
need to define the different kinds of
hackers they are because they have
different roles and different
motivations and the way you identify
them is you can just look at them in a
room and pick out what color hats they
are wearing because they have all this
colorful Hudson
that's how do you know what sort of
hacker you're dealing with
this comes back from the old western
movies where the good guys had white
hats and the bad guys had black cats so
that kind of translated over to the
hacking community so we have the black
cats that the milk that's the malicious
people those who do bad stuff to do DDOS
attacks or if they do sufficient
campaigns or do malware and stuff like
that then we have the white hats they
are the people who are like pen testers
and things like that they do things
ethically and they do things with
permission
then they have the in-betweener that's
the gray hat they do things for good but
not not necessarily are always ethical
they may try and exploit somebody
without their permission and gambling on
that they will get a reward rather than
litigation for the disclosing what they
found
and then we have what I hope many of you
will go out today and be and that's the
green attackers that's the beginner
hackers who are starting their Journey
To Learn
which uh which is awesome they have
progressed Beyond The Script kiddie
level script kiddies are like people who
just find the tool that does some kind
of exploit but they don't know how it
works but they just use it
let me have the red hat hackers they are
not Linux fans but they are they hunt
other hackers take down big hacker
organizations and they kind of do
digital Warfare
and then we have the last one that's the
blue hat and they are people who are
like hired by companies prior to
releasing software to the to the public
if you are invited to try and find
experts
so they for instance Microsoft have had
a long tradition of having these blue
hat events where they invite notable
hackers to come in and check out new
versions of Windows or office and big
applications like that
and the idea is to find vulnerabilities
before things go into the wild and Patch
them before
so let's discuss
ing why are people able to expand
exp and the sad truth is basically
because we are developers we are humans
and we make mistakes
it's not necessarily mistakes that we
make on purpose it can be something that
we haven't thought about or overlooked
because software systems are pretty
complex and they have many moving parts
and you may not always have the full
picture and the full grasp of all the
little details that are going on in your
system and all the possibilities and
often the devil lies just in those
little details
and there's a big thing that's going on
that's we've involved in term that is we
trust others people's codes like it's
the best thing ever and it's totally
fine
we have all these libraries all these
packages all these Frameworks and that's
essentially others people's code that we
are trusting sometimes we have millions
of lines of other people codes and we
have like 10 lines over our own code in
our system
and trying to have like an overview of
all of that is nearly impossible but the
problem is that once you include other
other people's code in your system
you're also including their
vulnerabilities
also we developers we tend to fall in
love with our tool Stacks it's like we
if we have a couple of tools we love we
try to use those for everything even
though they may not be intended to to
that use case it's kind of like if
you're building a house and you need to
pour a concrete for the foundation you
got a hammer and you need to mix that
cement you would be better with the
cement mixer but it's I'll just use my
hammer
and I'm going to tell you a story of
back when I got hacked because I really
got hacked once at my work
and this cinnamon bun picture is going
to make sense in a bit but what happened
was I was hired as a CTO in the startup
and we were going to take over the world
we were going to build this big giant
e-advertising platform that was going to
run on all the e-magazines and
e-newspapers in Europe and in Northern
America
and the idea was that we will have this
like multimedia type ads with games and
stuff in them that you can win prizes so
if you play the game you want a price
you gotta you got a barcode sent to your
phone and you can go to like 7-Eleven
and scan that barcode and you've got a
price like a cup of coffee or something
like that
problem is that when you're the CTO in a
tiny startup you're also the tech lead
on the principal architect and also the
lead programmer
so I had to build this thing myself as a
one-man show
um but this is back before there were
any clouds there weren't any containers
there weren't any like AWS or serverless
things
we had boxes that's all we had
so I had to set up this distributed
real-time system that was going to serve
all of Europe
so I had to travel around set up racks
in data centers all over Europe and get
this thing to work together
and then there was this one little
detail on top of all this is because
back then to do what we then called Rich
content basically games on websites
there was only one thing you could use
because there weren't any Canvas apis OR
Graphics apis in the browsers back then
so you have to use a plugin and that
plugin was Flash
and if you have heard about Flash you
know how awful it is and if you haven't
well here's a kick a Kickstart course
so this is Flash it was made by macro
media it was intended to make like these
interactive presentations that you can
burn on a CD and share
and if you notice it does have a code
bin window
but if it's here there's a timeline
and you may wonder what that is for and
there's also these drawing tools and the
primary use case for this was to create
animations that you can click on so this
is actually made for making cartoons
and it did have a programming interface
on top of that I can do like listen to
user actions and manipulate State and
stuff like that
and it was called actionscript it was
based on acne script so it's basically
JavaScript
and this all got compiled into this
binary format and you can share that and
it will it will be played through a
plugin in your browser
the problem with this thing is a it
wasn't intended to be secure it wasn't
intended to do anything that had to do
with anything that had value such as
prices and stuff like that
um there was one big thing that I didn't
know I didn't had overlooked this detail
because it was compiled so I thought
that's fine but it turns out it's really
easy to reverse engineer it's easy to
decompile and a Swedish student did just
that with my system
and by doing so he figured out how he
worked he figured out how the game
worked uh with this awful game where you
had to kill flies and get them off the
cinnamon buns why you wanted to to kill
insects and
and have cinnamon buns at the same time
I don't know but that was the game
but he managed to find the back end call
that we used to generate the price
tickets
and that made that meant that he could
generate as many price tickets as he
wanted
which
was bad and I got this call early in the
morning with my CEO who was furious at
me because evidently this person had
picked up 73 cinnamon buns in one single
day and that was a big problem
my immediate response was that person
really likes cinnamon buns
she didn't think that was funny but I
thought it was pretty funny
and then I got called in I went into
this big meeting crisis meeting with the
board and everyone and I had to stand
there and said this sorry sir it's my
fault so I'm liable all that stuff
but I I got kind of sick of getting
yelled that's why I thought I had to
spend this into something positive so I
said no no we're not going to do this
we're not going to to hide this away
what we are going to do we're going to
get a newspaper and you the CEO you're
going to go to Sweden you're going to
get a big case of cinnamon buns and find
this person and publicly thank him for
his service
and then they did just that so at the
end of the story is in the biggest
newspaper in Sweden the CEO and this
hacker with a big case of Hitman Bunsen
going like this and this happy happy new
story about how he helped us fight
vulnerabilities in our system and we
thanked him for it so that was kind of
our bug Bounty program I guess
impromptu
so how can we how can we prevent stuff
like this from happening to our
applications because usually what we do
is we build our applications and we get
a pen test team going and they test it
out and they say everything is okay we
have to fix these things and then we go
live
but after that first pen test
um at your next push of a commits well
that pen test is basically invalid
because you haven't tested a pen tested
the new stuff
so one one point I I'm trying to make
with this talk is that if you have those
capabilities in your team to kind of
like continuously pen test your
applications
well that's beneficial because that
makes you enables you to find more flaws
and vulnerabilities easily
and a great way of gaining those skill
sets because it kind of seems like this
esoteric thing that may not be
approachable and uh to many people
uh there is a way to to kind of like
build this up in a ordered fashion and
build those capabilities in your team
and one such mechanism is called CTF
and I want to let Elliot from the
incredible show Mr robots the one show
on television actually gets hacking
right
let him explain what it is
you have to capture the flag it's like
the hacker Olympics
teams around the world compete to solve
challenges reverse engineering protocol
exploitation forensics
entire city suffering an energy crisis
while they're here exercising their
inner Anarchy
yeah so if it was kind of hard to hear
but he says it's the hacker Olympics and
you get to get to exercise your inner
Anarchy that's awesome and it talked
about reverse engineering protocol
exploitation and a couple of different
kinds of attacks
and ctfs are just that they're they're
kind of this organized gamified way of
learning adversarial techniques you have
like these challenges that are designed
to Encompass one type of vulnerability
or one type of attack or one kind of
mechanism to to to try and figure out
how hacks happen
the cool thing about this is they are an
incredible Catalyst for Learning and
gaining insights into this kind of mode
of thinking
because it enables you to think
differently about stuff it enables you
to think like an attacker you would
start to to fuss your inputs and start
to be curious in pokken probe at your
systems to to figure out what's what
would happen if somebody did this
because we tend to kind of trust our
users and think that no nobody will ever
put this into that field or something
like that but what happens if you do
and that's cool and you do this by
solving these challenges
and we actually have had a couple of
ctfs inside of the MB and we had one
last fall that we opened up the entire
group not just like the tech people but
the entire group
and man did that spark engagement it was
so awesome because suddenly everybody
was talking about cyber security and
hacking and reverse engineering and
stuff like that so we had like these
awesome conversations around the coffee
machine cross divisions and cross
business areas and that was pretty fun
and my favorite email that I ever got in
DMB was from a lawyer in legal who sent
me a letter of apology because he had
performed a SQL injection attack on one
of the challenges in my CTF
and he had accidentally deleted the
entire database so he wanted to say
sorry and when when the lawyers in your
legal department are performing SQL
injection attacks well that's just
you're doing something right that's so
awesome
so that's my favorite email and I must
admit it's so fun just to be able to go
to the villain or the bad guy for once
and you can do so in a safe environment
so we have these challenges or channels
as they are referred to they come in
different categories and those
categories are kind of designed to kind
of flip your mind into what kind of mode
you need and what kind of tools you
would need to solve the challenge
and they're also tuned into different
kinds of things they are trying to teach
you so we have like crypto that's not
Bitcoin it's cryptography so it's all
about breaking encryption and breaking
codes
it's also about will teach you about
weaknesses from different encryption
schemes and stuff like that we have
stego which is steganography which is
basically when you're hiding something
inside something else so you can hide a
binary file inside an image that nobody
would know it's there
then we have forensics where you get to
analyze Network traffic or file systems
and stuff like that try and find digital
Clues we have reverse engineering and
now we're getting into the real hacker
territory
that's where I have to figure out the
program how it works and figure out how
to exploit it
then we have vulnerabilities which is
usually third-party vulnerabilities that
are probably known that you have to
figure out how they work and how to
exploit them so that's other other
people's code
and then we have web which is everything
above but all tuned into some kind of
web app
and then we have pawning which is like
the creme de La Creme category is where
you get to actually take over a remote
system take over a box and own that so
you can do whatever you want with it
there's several different kinds of tools
we use to this and these are just a
non-exhaustive list I'm not going to go
through them but they are everything
from just the operating system with some
tools installed there's some for
cracking passwords there's some for
tracking codes there's some for dealing
with data
one of my favorite is GDB P Peter
Edition that's a version of the new
debugger with some added tools to do
reverse engineering and do things like
buffer overflows and things like that
which I think is really fun
and there's things that we can use to to
decompile and one of my favorite tools
there as well is called gidra it's this
tool from NSA
that they decided to release to the
public you can give it away for free
which is pretty generous and it can
decompile native binaries and get not
just the assembly code but it can get
actually a pseudo c-like code so it's
really easy to figure out how the
program works by using gear
so let's talk about web because that's
this addition so we're not going to go
into buffer overflows and stuff like
that today we're going to give the web a
chance
and the web was invented by this guy you
may or may not know him is Tim
berners-lee
and his intention was to create this
like shared document system where we can
share documents and link to other
documents and share information
but it kind of evolved from that it
evolved from having like static content
to be dynamic content
and then we started to interact over the
web we started to have chats and have
like these message groups and things
like that where we're using it for
direct communication
and then we allowed non-technical people
to come onto these platforms to create
content like Twitter or YouTube and
social media and stuff like that
and it's evolved into the primary Global
application platform that we serve our
applications on it's anything from
navigation on your phone to uh to
ordering a room service at your hotel
it's all web apps
and if you had asked or Tim Burns Lee or
Brian Knight back in the day if they
were ready to produce the next Global
application platform they probably would
have made some different choices
and this all posts new vulnerabilities
new challenges because it's a different
mode of operation than what we're used
to with classical applications
and there are really many types of
experts for the web there's so many so
this is a non-exhaustive list we have
cross-site scripting we have SQL
injection template poisoning prototype
pollution misconfigurations broken
authentication phishing spearfishing
third party vulnerabilities and so many
more
there's actually so many web exploits
that there's some people decided we need
an interest group to handle all this so
there was this group called all wasp
stands for the open web application
security project
was founded back in 2001 and their main
goal is to kind of spread awareness
about common vulnerabilities and common
threats to web applications
and they released this top 10 list which
is famous for
saying what are the number top 10 top 10
stats that's threatening web
applications at the moment
and these are the most critical security
risks that are facing web applications
at that time and there's this other
project as well which is called the cve
database which is lesser known but it's
very very well known in cyber security
circles it's this public repository of
known exploits and known vulnerabilities
with examples and pocs of how to perform
them
every time a new expert is found is
given an identifier which is CV and the
year it happened it was discovered and
some kind of sequence number
they are primarily used for risk
assessments to figure out the threats in
threat Horizons of your applications to
see where your risks are based on your
the vulnerabilities of your dependencies
but for ctfers it's a awesome Treasure
Trove of goodies with so many fun stuff
that you can pick from there to figure
out how to solve the challenges
and there are many ctfs that you can try
out there's some public ones like that
are online like hack the Box try hack me
and Pico CTF Google arranges one yearly
they use it kind of in in the
recruitment process as well
we have this oh they called thing called
The Juice Shop with which is this Docker
image of a web application which
basically I've implemented all the old
wasp security flaws in one application
so it's the least least secure web apps
ever written
then in DMB we have hack the bank that
we launched at the this conference that
you can participate in now is going on
now and I'm going to give some examples
from that later
another big hacker conferences like
Defcon and blackhead that is they have
ctfs and those are just like the
Olympics because that's the one where
people send teams from all over the
world
and now enough talking let's check out
some of these challenges some of these
exploits live
so I have to close teams
see because that's not what we're trying
to do let's see if I can make this
happen
no
I have to end the slideshow
okay nice
awesome so now I'm going to do some
things live so that they may or may not
work so this is kind of high risk but
we're going to give it a go anyways
so
by the sound again how many of you make
some kind of web app
hey awesome
great so let's see if we can find some
fun demos
uh let me start by going online and
going here
and I will get into the hack the bank
portal so this is the this is the CTF
portal that I made
and you can log in using your Google or
Microsoft account or you can register
for one and here are the flags and these
are the challenges that you're about
that you have to take
so let's check out some web challenges I
think we have this one Santa's bingo
so the challenge are always like this
they have like a text uh and there's
sometimes there's a hint
and there's always clues in things like
the title or the the challenge text or
or the hint
let's see what so Santa decided to give
you an early Christmas present all you
have to do is guess a value easy right
so let's go into this page
this looks like a mess and Santa is
having a lightsaber battle with the
Grinch that's fun
so make a guess this is not a normal
Bingo you only need to get one right and
you will get a present so I guess I will
try and
guess something
too bad didn't make it
so this is this is it seems to be using
PHP because there's index PHP there
and before I do anything else let me do
some Recon and use walk web to see what
I'm dealing with because that will give
me some some information that I can use
to maybe find if there's an exploit so
you can see it's using Apache 2.452
is running Debian and we have php73
so that's that gives me some ideas what
can be going on
let me check out some more
so it has this link here so it says test
ignore
of course you should behave good and
ignore that no we shouldn't so clicking
that
it gives me the source code for the
index file and why does it do that
well because it has this if test here
that says if test is in the query string
then it will highlight the file that's
the base name of PHP itself so PHP
itself is everything that's that's here
and base name will return the file name
part of that
so that's front and we have this regex
match that says if config PHP is in that
query string we should say hahaha you
didn't say the magic word
so let's test that so let me let me try
if I can just go to config PHP because
that's evidently a file
that doesn't work
so maybe I can call that in context of
index PHP because then base name will
return config
you didn't say the magic word so I
evidently hit that corner case what if I
do this and Tack on test
uh that didn't work because I still hit
that that thing so let's let's analyze
this a little bit so we have this ray x
match let me just take this because
regex is this one thing that I always
think that one day I will learn how to
do that properly and I never do and I
always end up Googling it anyways
but that's uh do reg x101 and let the
machine tell me what's going on
so it says it matches config the
characters literally it matches the dot
literally with an escape character
it matches the forward slash literally
with an escape character
it matches the star token and it's
greedy so it takes everything beyond
that and then it searched that it's the
end of the string
so let's let's see what's going on so if
I say config.php
it will hit that if I do a slash
it will hit it if I do anything else
after then it won't match the regex so I
need to put something after this
in order to to to get to that things let
me try that out so if I do index PHP
config PHP
and I do slash something and I do
tests
doesn't work but again again if I get a
fail a fail so it failed to open a file
ASDF
so that means the base name now return
this instead of the other one so I need
to figure out how to get base name to
return this
so before I do that let me just oh go
back there
let me check out what base name does
check out that function see if the other
is anything interesting in the manual
about this function
so it says it Returns the trailing name
component of a path so basically
everything after the last slash
there's a caution here base name is
local aware so for you to see the
correct Baseline with multi-byte
character pads the matching Locale must
be set using set Locale if a path
contains characters which are invalid
for the current locale
then the behavior base name is undefined
an undefined Behavior that's something
we can exploit because that means we
don't know what what will happen so
that's cool
and this means that if there's any
characters in the path that it can't
decode based on the encoding that's set
then something fun can happen
and I know some things about this setup
it's using Debian Linux and is using
Apache and php7
so I can create a little test script to
test out what what happens let's see
it's PHP base
uh
yeah PHP base so I have a test I have a
test script
come on type
so it's it's pretty easy so all it will
do is it will go through everything for
up to up to 0x100
and it will try and evaluate base name
plus that character against this string
and see what it returns basically
and in order to replicate the
environment I just created a quick
Docker file I'm going to just run the
base from the Apache and I just copy
this script over
install the dependencies
let me try so if I just do Docker build
Dash t
PHP test dot we'll build that image for
me
I didn't type that correctly
now build is not built so like this
and I can do a Docker run and I'd make
it Interactive
and I will do PHP test and let's just do
slash bin slash Bash
so now I have an interactive shell to
that box
and the test PHP is the same one
see if I do now do PHP test PHP
it will just go through that Loop and lo
and behold Let's see we see something
interesting here
so whenever the character is something
within uh between zero
and 127 meaning the ASCII characters if
we return that character but the minute
we are over into the Extended space of
ASCII well then it will return
config.php as we trigger that undefined
behavior that we read about
so that means if I add a non-ascii
character to the end of this it should
return config PHP so let us test that
out
I will do
config.php and I will need slash and
some kind of custom characters let's do
FF
and I need the test query string so that
will cost base 10 to return conflict PHP
instead of that special character and
since test is set it will highlight that
for me so I'm going to do that I see the
constant conflict PHP
so now I'm exploiting a floor in PHP
to find the file I shouldn't be able to
see
which is pretty cool
so that's that's one and now I can take
that flag
I can take that flag I can go back here
and Santa's Bingo and I can just enter
that and get my points
so now I saw that because I see the flag
so that's one little exploit let's see
if we can find some more
let me exit this
uh what else to do let's do one more PHP
since we are in PHP territory
there's in the pawn category there's one
called uh receipt
uploader where's that
receipt this is this is cool
so this is a awesome web application
where you can upload a receipt
and let's see I have prepared a couple
of things because it's probably somebody
takes a picture receipt and uploads of
pictures I have this awesome picture of
a cat
so I will take that and upload that and
see what happens
so it says it's a genuine image PNG
and I can click it
and I find my image that seems benign
enough right
what happens if I if I create a PHP file
and upload that can I run that that'd be
beneficial right maybe they haven't
thought about this the designers of this
system
let me upload that and see what happens
no invalid image file upload failed try
again
so evidence tries to figure out if this
is a real image
so what could I do well images they have
this they are binary but they have this
one place inside for metadata it's
called XF data and it's it's just this
thing to to to put in things like what's
the size what's the date that was
captured if it was captured by a camera
what type of camera and stuff like that
and I have this tool called exif tool
it's a certificate if I give that cat I
will see these metadatas and these are
stored in plain text inside the image
but what I could do is I can add some
metadata to this thing so I'm just going
to say comment equals
and what happens if I give that some
boom come on correct keyboard layouts
awesome if I give that PHP code so let's
do PHP info
see if that that will do anything
so
so now
no no space
so now if I check the cat out I can see
that there's a comment section and it
has that PHP code let's see if that does
something
so I will take again upload this cat
PNG and let's see what happens
oh didn't do anything
but that is because the preprocessor
expects the extension to be a PHP in
order to do PHP processing
so if I just do copy of cat PHP to cat a
cat PNG to cut PHP
maybe it doesn't check the extension
so let's see what that does
so now I uploaded that it didn't it
still says it's an image
but it so the it checks the magic number
in at the file header and it that
evaluates the PNG what happens if I
click this
well PHP that's what PHP does best screw
everything up for you so you can see you
can see the bytes of the of the of the
image then it evaluates PHP info and
I've puts that to the screen and then at
the bottom we get the rest of the image
because PHP goes ah I don't know what
this is hey PHP I know PHP yes I'm best
awesome
so now we know that we can execute code
so now we can manipulate this so if I do
if I do exit tool
and I do let's say comment
and let's let's set this to something
more malicious rather than than PHP info
let's do shell exec
and see if I can run LS
for instance
uh come on where's there it is
and you'd have to do cat PHP this time
so now now I added the code to do the
shell exact just to verify it's there
so if I upload this I should be able to
list out some files so I upload that cat
again
you got a new name and now we can see
comment and here is a file name here is
a file name here is a file name so this
is all the other people's uploads I was
trying to solve this challenge
so evidently I'm a bit far up so let me
go One Directory up and see if that
helps
so now I'm executing shell commands on a
remote system through an image which is
pretty neat
so let's see if I can do that and here I
can see I have command flag txt index
PHP and probably fly txt is what I'm
looking for
so I can just change it this to a cat
and your flag txt
it's now going to use the cat to cut the
flag
that's
so let's see if we can do that and there
we cut out the flag watch a lot of Mr
robots and I can take that back and
exchange that for points as well
so that is if that is also a fun one or
PHP but let's go let's go deeper
let's see something else in action
how about we do some cross-eyed
scripting that's fun
so I'm going to do this and I'm going to
just
I'm going to restart my container just
to make sure that
it is behaving because this is kind of
unstable because people are attacking it
live as we speak and sometimes since
crosstalk scripting is enabled they
break it
but this is also back in the in the
portal let's go to Flags
believe this is in the web
so it's called admin jokes
so here we have a link to admin jokes
let's see if that container has spawned
then it's done so that means we can
start attacking this thing
so let's do this
so this is a messaging wall I guess if I
refresh I can see there's an admin
pasting to it they're posting to it
and evidently there are jokes so what do
you call a fake noodle an impasta
that's great admin thank you
so let's see if we can do some
cross-site scripting because I can all
seemingly type messages
so I can do that
my name is Sam today that's awesome so
let me try the the the basic cross-eyed
scripting demo that you always see
adding a script tag with alerts and that
didn't work so they did a good job they
tried they escaped these characters so I
get the text and not evaluate the script
but have they thought about everything
when they made this how about if I do
some sneaky encoding to this script what
will happen then so if I were to go to
URL encoder
and URL encode this will that pass there
their tests or reg access for
identifying the script tags what happens
then and then we have xss confirmed
and this is usually where all cross-site
scripting demos and because yes we have
a pop-up and you may ask why is that
dangerous well it's dangerous because
this script is evaluated not by just by
you but any other who've used this
portal so how can we exploit that well
what I would like to do is is probably
something I need to get from this admin
maybe I would want to get the admins
session or his password or something
like that
so let's see let's let's I have prepared
a little JavaScript because this is what
I would like to like to execute so I've
set up what's called a request bin or
request catcher
so this
this here this will get some this will
get a request if somebody's made so I
can test it out with using curl so I can
use this
so that sends the get requests and I get
the confirmation that our post request
and I get a confirmation that that has
happened
so
now I want to have the admin
post his cookies to my request pin so I
can steal his session or figure out some
other secrets so having running this
fetch thing where I just send the
cookies to that endpoint would be
beneficial
but that's not going to work because
there's this thing called course who who
which is this things that make all
developers who do web apps crazy because
they only try to figure out what do I
need to put in which header to make this
work because where do I put the star to
make everything talk to each other
because what happens now is if I run
this code against this page
I will get the course
rejection from the browser saying that
no you can't call this this domain from
this domain because that's not allowed
by any headers that I've seen
so we need to find a way to cut to
circumvent that
and we there is a way to do so because
there are many ways to make requests off
of web pages
and one such thing is the one I do do in
trial too
so if I do trial two
we can see I take the cookies and I make
an image
and I set the source of that image to be
my request Catcher And I append the
cookie to the query string
and this will be fine because you're
allowed to link to images anywhere
because people you see the ends and
stuff like that for images so images are
not blocked by the browser this is why
if I go here and the URL encode this
script
and post that to the wall if everything
works
hopefully xss is confirmed still
and if I go to my request catcher you
can see the admin calls are coming in at
the top and I can read the cookie
so if I take that cookie and I go into
up
thank you
take the cookie and I go into URL decode
this time
paste it there
I need to do it twice because it's
doubly encoded
and there I get my flag hashtag I eat
cookies for breakfast
which is cool so that's cross-eyed
scripting
so let's check out another fun thing do
you have time yeah we have a couple of
minutes
uh let's this is a this is a really fun
one so let's do uh um serialize
this is uh
uh Now Let's do let's do
yeah let's do on serialize
that that's a fun one so that is this
let's see if I can find it
um
cereal no it's important
it's important
and when it's important that means that
there is a there's a chance that we can
get remote access to this thing
so this is the Grinch serial killer
if we look at the task
it says that we identify the villains
through Santa's blog
and there are these are the top 10 most
Wanted characters on the North Pole
and there was
5941 applicants to this list so go
figure it seems a bit uncivilized which
is
an odd number maybe that means something
that's that's
keep a note to that word and just do
some Recon so let's just do what what
web to see what we're working with
and we will find out some neat stuff so
it's powered by Express
you can see that here that means this is
a node.js application
and it's it's hints to something about
serialization it's a serial killer it's
uncivilized so maybe node has some kind
of vulnerability when it comes to
serialization so let's check that out
there's also also this this number so
let me just take that number and I will
Google that number and node.js and see
what I've what I find
and here we can see that there's a cve
attached to that number
that's the common vulnerabilities and
expert database
so if I go into that database and see
it says that an issue was discovered in
the node serialized package for node.js
untrusted data passed into the unserious
function can be exploited to achieve
arbitrary code execution
that's fun why does that happen let me
check out that package
so node serialize let me check out the
package
and we can see that okay
what is this thing
why didn't you get a
what is the no read me
it's the wrong package
no
okay let's go to the GitHub them
so uh
this serialized an object including its
function into Json
so not only
not only can you serialize data like
name Bob but you can also see it as
Behavior like this function
and that is probably somebody thought
that was a good idea but JavaScript has
a couple of quirks one of those quirks
is what's known as an immediately
invoked function expression
if you don't know what that is it's this
thing so I can define a function
that is anonymous and it has a body
where it does let's say let's say just a
console like if I was a YouTuber this is
where I would probably go please
subscribe but I am not a YouTuber but
I'm going to do it anyway and let's do
return zero and that's that and if I
close that param and I do this to invoke
that function what happens is that
function will get invoked immediately
and the result is then returned as a
value
so it says please sell Ben returns zero
so if I serialize that function the
minute that is unserialized or
deserialized well then that function is
invoked so I can send a function that
will be run by the server
that's fun but let's figure out where I
can do this because there are no inputs
so let me check out the network Tab and
see what's going on if there's any fun
stuff I can export there
so I can see there's no Most Wanted and
I get this package this is a cookie that
and let me see if I can do anything with
that it's
and it's HTTP only so I can't steal it
or anything
but that's base 64 decodes that's decode
that thing
so a lo and behold that's a Json object
why do you think the chances are that
this is the serialized on the server
side before it before it's evaluated
when it gets back
Let's test it out let's see if I can
change the name I'll change it to esper
for fun
and I would take this and we will go to
encode
now just encode it and come on encode
that for me please
I'll just not take this because what
happens is that if I change this cookie
when I do my next request it's sent back
to the server
so let's see what happens now so if I
take this
and I can now see that I'm logged in
Aspen so that means that that was
evaluated server side
fun that means I can craft my exploits
so the expert is pretty pretty simple
let me just cut it out
so it uses
um
it is just this normal Json and it uses
this prefix for the function to let that
serialized Library know that this is a
function
and here I have this Anonymous function
as an immediately invoked one
and you can see that it does a response
a shell and it calls that through a
socket through this to to this port
and it's immediately invoked so it's in
both the minute it hits the server so in
order for this to work I need to have a
terminal that's available that's
listening on that port
that will get the Callback and that I
that way I can set up my reverse shell
so here I have a machine in Azure that's
called Arna
and what I will do is I will set up
netcat to listen on this port
and I will take my little exploit
which is it's just sponsored child
process and runs bin bash and then it's
pipes that to this socket
so if I do that here adds that the doing
code
and
I can take this whole thing
paste that in here and let me just make
this smaller
so you can see the terminal as well so
you can see the connection coming back
so what I'll do now is I will update
that and I will refresh this page and
that didn't work because it rewrote my
cookie so let me just do it once again
and the minute I and now now you can see
down here
it called back and I'm sending it at on
anymore I'm at node sandbox that means
that I now have open shell to the server
running that so like this is the index
that is where the that is the source
code for the server there you can see
that and if I do list out the root
directory that's usually where the flag
is and there there it is so I can just
cut out flag.txt that's my secret
so that's how I exploited a known
vulnerability in a third-part library
where somebody thought it was a good
idea to be able to serialize functions
so that's the last demo I think we have
time for so let me just do this last
slide with the takeaways for you all
so let's start from current slide
so
my the whole point of this thing was to
show you that experts are fun and they
are good to to do
and ctfs are really fun and educationals
and they can really enrich your teams
and your in the way you build your
applications
because building these offensive skills
that kind of changes how you view
security and it will make your systems
more secure
and I want you all to go home be curious
and fuss all your inputs and play with
your applications and try to break them
because that is if you discover
something well that's something you
won't have to to worry about in the
future
so put it in your hoodies and go out and
hack hack hack because it's so much fun
thank you so much
any questions
we have like one minute
[Applause]
yeah I can't see
[Music]
for memory manipulation I I'm old school
I use Gennady burger and I just fast the
inputs and view all the registers and
memory addresses to see what happens but
there's Pawn tools which is this python
library that would kind of makes him
even more easy because there's like
these pattern generators and Searchers
that can like find all the offsets and
memory for you and you can search for
for which it has this database like libc
to find which version of lip C you're
linked against and stuff like that so
you can find all the Rob gadgets and fun
stuff like that
yeah my other talks that's called just
how hacking works there we go into rock
Bing and memory manipulation and buffer
overflows and that stuff as well so
check that out if you have a chance any
other questions
huh
when you have to stop
yeah you should never break the law you
should do what you have permission to do
and that's why ctfs are cool because you
have permission to break them they're
they're there for you to break so you
learn so it's it's safe yeah
where do you find
it's really hard to hear you can
somebody relay
yeah so
yeah so Google CTF is one and there's
the hack the Box try hack me pico ctfs
these are these platforms we have which
have like continuous CTF challenges
posted to them all the time we have a
hacked Bank going at NDC now that you
can join uh just go to our stand and you
will find how to join
so so yeah and there's also the Juice
Shop that's this Docker image that you
can pull down it's pretty awesome pretty
fun and the kind of entry level but it's
fun
well then That's all folks